yeah on the bump today for the
pittsburgh pirates is
mitch keller 25 year old right henry's
making his seventh start of the season
and his 24th start of his career he's
two and four with a high area of 7.81 27
and two-thirds innings pitch 26
strikeouts
pretty good in the strikeout to innings
pitched ratio but the walks are a little
high left-handed batteries hitting 322
riders righty's hitting 259.
and then at 216. he's got four home runs
and
eight rbis
here's the pitch and with talkman
running it's taken talkman will make it
in after the throw is a little bit late
the tag laid he slides in safely with a
steal
pitch was i guess called a strike i
maybe i just blinked didn't look like a
strike to me but it was called a strike
by corey blazer talkman steals his way
into scoring position another element of
mike talkman's game
buster little dribbler third base side
he may have himself a hit he does
the magic wando of buster posey first
and third well most his hits i mentioned
he's leading the club and hits with 31.
most of his hits have been hit pretty
hard that wasn't on the hard hit scale
right there first and third one out for
the giants in a scoreless game alex
dickerson comes up
and on the first pitch a slow roller
they're going to try to turn two and
they won't and the giants lead one
nothing
man dickerson hit that so poorly that it
stayed out of a double play giants get a
run out of it posey forced down at
second two down but the giants will take
the run it's one nothing for the pitch
we had a breaking ball hit high and deep
out to center field reynolds just shy of
the track will bring it in and the
inning is through giants pick up a run
on a walk and a hit and a man left on
but through a half inning san francisco
one and the pirates coming up
frasier's been a tough out for everybody
this year but especially in the series
for the giants as he comes in hitting
318.
wood struck out 29 guys this year 24
have been with that slider
darren ruff all over the place in this
series one out
newman hitting 209 with a home run he's
got eight driven in if the leg comes
home inside ball four missed with a
fastball so the walk to newman
it's a pirate aboard for brian reynolds
reynolds
coming in at 301
on base at 400.
and he got him throw down to second is
not in time
it'll be a strikeout and a stolen base
oh good slider by alex wood down below
the strike zone to reynolds
nice throw of a buster but anticipating
how kepler's going to talk about this
best he might have been interfered with
so you don't have to call
the hitter out although in this case he
was out anyway but you can also you can
say the hitter is entitled to finish his
swing with a follow through but if in
that natural motion he gets in the way
of the catcher you can force that runner
to go back alex wood is making his first
appearance against the pirates since
2019 he's three and three in his career
in 10 ball games against pittsburgh a
309 lifetime era
one two got him swinging a slider nasty
down and in fourth strikeout for alex
wood
one hit one stranded top of the order
coming up for the giants oh what a great
season he's been having coming in third
in the national league in batting
average
318 hitter
leading the league and hits the pitch
and is swinging a little pop back of
second that's down for his 50th hit of
the season
and frazier on pace for a 200 hit year
here at the quarter point you know great
formula he avoids strikeouts gets the
ball put in play and you know because of
that he's going to find a lot of holes
and you can't defend him you have to
spread everybody out you got to create a
lot of opportunities out there a lot of
holes for the balls to fall in
2-2
reynolds check swing roller to third
coming in to scoop it up longoria throws
off one foot to first in time nice play
there's the classic longoria defense
that was well done here's the pitch
crawford lines this one down the right
field line a fair ball it goes into the
corner where stokes is going to dig it
out
on the way to third is longoria into
second with a double is crawford
2-0 pitch hunting dead red gets the
pitch he wants down and in right where
he likes it spins on it
another solid hit bap by brandon
crawford
oh he went he certainly did in the dirt
in the block by stallings
back-to-back strikeouts and now you just
got to get by the pitcher this slider
looks good and again the luxury of
having jacob stotlings behind home plate
where you can bury that pitch and throw
it down below the strike zone and he
keeps it in front of you
oh and two on the pitcher wood
and the crowd starting to
get into it with keller 02 pitch
he struck him out looking
a big league moment for keller how about
mitch keller he had second and third and
nobody out and he strikes out three
giants
in a row bases loaded nobody out giants
had second and third nobody out and
mitch keller pitched through it we'll
see if alex wood can match that here
there's the pitch and a swinging a soft
fly ball
deep enough i think now to left of
center talkman's got it here comes
stallings to the plate he'll score
tom gets the job done a sacrifice fly
and the pirates tie the game at one as
keller waits and he bounces this one to
longoria he's gonna go to the bag as he
steps on third and that's gonna end the
inning so the damage could have been
worse bases loaded nobody out pirates
score one
so two balls two strikes the pitch
swinging a high papa
foul territory
rough and it's dubon who makes the
running catch
as he falls into that screen down the
right field line
which protects everybody from foul balls
and it protected him from falling into
the seats
so a terrific catch on a foul pop-up by
mauricio dubon ruff was giving chase but
he had no chance and then out of nowhere
came dubon
keeps an eye on it catches it right in
the heel of the glove puts that second
hand over the top which you're supposed
to do on second is reynolds it's two and
two to jacob stalling
and the pitch swing and a miss he struck
him out and they'll end the inning so
with the help of the
pick off play the giants
get through it without allowing a run
giants have runners now at the corners
with mauricio dubonne at the plate
he's set up way outside he shortens the
bun in the pitch goes right by the
catcher
longoria will break for the plate and
the giants go ahead man i i i can't
remember the last time i saw a catcher
set up so far outside and then clay
holmes threw it even farther than that
here's the o2 swinging a line drive up
the middle it's through for a base head
posey will stop at second not good
seeing him limp down the steps so
michael perez is going to uh take over
behind the plate james would
love to get an extra run their lead is
just one two to one
ski drives one to deep right field it is
out of here so mike yaski catches up to
one his fifth home run of the year that
was a bolt and it gives the giants some
breathing room four 4-1 here in the
ninth inning man is that good to see we
do know that it's one and two
to adam frazier
and this is hit out
into center field and this should do it
and that's the ball game
so the giants end up
winning another sunday ball game